[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau data
d'interdire la désobéissance civile
était la mode de contestation légitime
dans une démocratie peut-on accepter que
des citoyens refusent refusent de
remplir une obligation légale sous
prétexte qu'elle est contraire à leurs
principes vaste problème d'autant plus
vaste que la plupart des mouvements
contestataires se réclament aujourd'hui
de la désobéissance civile les
écologistes les féministes les
antispécistes les anciens pour les
antilles vax les racistes et les anti
racistes ceux qui aident les migrants
entrées en france et ceux qui veulent
les en empêcher même les supporters de
donald trump qui ont envahi le capitole
l'année dernière invoquait le droit la
résistance passe un pouvoir inique et
dans le convoi de la liberté qui bloque
en ce moment même la ville d'ottawa au
canada où parmi ceux qui se sont élancés
ce matin sur les routes de france pour
rejoindre paris d'ici vendredi soir à
vitesse réduite il y a sûrement des
lecteurs de david thoreau alors comment
réagir face à la désobéissance civile
qu'en penser pour en débattre nous avons
invité vincent brain gart vous a dit
votre avocat pénaliste associé au sein
du cabinet de william bourdon vous
intervenez dans des contentieux
concernant les libertés fondamentales
vous avez défendu des filets jaunes des
gens ayant aidé des migrants entre en
france des écologistes des militants
antispécistes des lanceurs d'alert et
vous venez de publier avec le
journaliste jérôme hourdeaux
revendiquons le droit à la désobéissance
chez fayard alors dans une démocratie
est ce que les citoyens ont le droit à
la désobéissance civile pour vous en
tout cas le droit à des hobbies sens
figure dans les textes et il a même
valeur constitutionnelle puisque si on
se réfère par exemple à l'article 2 de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de 1789 on reconnaît un droit
à la résistance à l'oppression donc
après toute la question est de savoir si
ce droit à la résistance à l'oppression
peut ou non être applicable en fonction
des conditions démocratiques que nous
traversons on sait aussi qu'un droit d
obéissance reconnu pour les
fonctionnaires notamment parce qu'ils
ont un devoir d'obéissance mais qui cède
lorsque par exemple et les ordres sont
illégaux et puis il ya aussi tout un
mouvement de jurisprudence qui admet ce
mode de comportement notamment à la
faveur aussi de la jeunesse pense de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
de la liberté d'expression
yves michaud vous êtes philosophe je
vous ai reçus récemment sur ce plateau
pour votre dernier livre l'art c'est
bien fini aux éditions gallimard vous
avez également écrit sur la crise de la
citoyenneté je titrais citoyenneté et
loyauté qui était paru chez quéro en
2017 est ce qu'on a le droit à une démo
baylet désobéissance civile dont je ne
sais pas si tu dire que ça dépend en
fait ce qu'on entend par désobéissance
civile est ce qu'on entend par
résistance bon moi j'ai une très longue
histoire dans ce domaine là puisque j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur la violence dès
les années 70 et à l'époque je veux dire
l'alternative au terrorisme ou à la
révolution c'était je dirais la
résistance civile non violente
bon maintenant je dirais le droit de
résistance au sens où on invoque c'est
un droit de résistance très fort je veux
dire ca réseau c'était inclus dans la
théorie l'obtiennent par exemple c'est à
dire le citoyen doit d'ailleurs être
armés ces doudous le port des armes aux
états unis soutiendraient est rare mais
au cas où le magistrat enfreint ses
obligations et donc il est besoin
d'exercer la raison bon maintenant moi
ce qui me gêne et c'est pour ça que je
suis pas trop pour ce qui me gêne c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on monnaie est en quelque
sorte le droit de résistance dans tous
les sens des tas de cas de figure et je
dirais ça donne plutôt une sonde
arbitraire des subjectivités aider et
des communautés qui il trouve que
embarrassant certains aspects de la loi
que ce soit je dirais des écologistes
des antispécistes que ce soit des pros
migrants des antilles migrants et ses
jeux ça me choque beaucoup si vous
voulez variable à l'assaut contre le
capitole peu pour un vrai look 1 c'est
vraiment de la blague je vais dire et ça
devrait être c'est uniquement parce
qu'ils étaient couverts par l'immunité
de trump qui équipent vais faire ça mais
sinon ça mérite je dirais la répression
la plus féroce oui ils ont bien ils ont
des ennuis après ils ont des ennuis
parce que des résultats du c1 pays de
juristes donc quelques on est sur vous a
frappé la ville jusqu'au casta peu après
la question à partir de quel moment elle
citoyen a le droit de désobéir si vous
prenez le cas emblématique du général de
gaulle en juin 40 il
refuse l'armistice et
en revanche vous prenez le quarteron de
généraux à la retraite d'avril 61 qui
lui refusent l'indépendance de l'algérie
quelle différence y at-il entre les deux
aucune si ce n'est que l'histoire a
donné raison à la et pas aux autres mais
comment est-ce qu'on s'y prend la 1 e et
non il va ya une vérité après c'est vrai
que je fais un juge et j'ai écouté avec
attention sur les multitudes de
subjectivité mais ce qui est certain
c'est que la période moderne la période
que nous traversons de graves
défaillances aussi nos systèmes
institutionnels
notre démocratie est un peu à bout de
souffle on le voit s'exprime de plus en
plus d'ailleurs ces mêmes reconnu par
toute une partie de la classe politique
et parce que justement vous avez on se
rapproche de ce point de rupture que
vous avez un ensemble citoyens qui
aujourd'hui ne se sentent plus
représentés par nos instances
représentatives le parlement qu'il joue
plus son rôle on him on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure sur les
questions de paix sanitaire de peste
vaccinale goût finalement qui sert
presque uniquement de courroie de
transmission au pouvoir exécutif sans
véritable pouvoir décisionnaire et si
vous avez des institutions qui ne jouent
plus véritablement leur rôle de
contre-pouvoir que soit le parlement que
ce soit d'autres institutions aussi des
autorités administratives indépendantes
la cncdh le défenseur des droits qui
rendent des avis qui sont parfois
extrêmement sévère mais dont on voit que
malheureusement il reste lettre morte et
donc je crois que c'est aussi ça la
question du droit des hobbies sens et
que vous avez évidemment un droit d
obéissance par rapport à des normes
aussi qu'on peut questionner on parlait
tout à l'heure des débitants qui aident
en tout cas les personnes en situation
irrégulière et je crois que le délit de
solidarité pose véritablement question
le fait de pouvoir récriminer des
personnes parce qu'elles viennent en
aide à des personnes en situation
irrégulière alors même qu' elle ne
poursuit pas forcément de bus monétaire
et de vue financier c'est aussi sans
s'est questionné la norme donc il ya non
seulement les cas dans lesquels on
questionne des normes qui apparaissent
soit complètement anachronique soit qui
apparaissent complètement dix prix
disproportionné et puis il ya une
désobéissance un peu plus générale
contenu aussi dans un état démocratique
par exemple sur la question des
décrocheurs de portraits et eu un
ensemble de décisions du président de la
république à présent à appliquer et on a
vu un ensemble des décisions qui étaient
parfois un peu contradictoire il y avait
notamment un jeu qui de façon
extrêmement courageuse avait dit hier il
avait reconnu un état de nécessité un
état de nécessité contenu précisément de
cette rupture de dialogue entre le
pouvoir exécutif et les manifestants il
se trouve que la colonisation a pas
forcément retenu cette analyse mais elle
avait au moins reconnu la nécessité de
prendre en compte la liberté d'informer
enfin la liberté d'expression il y avait
eu effectivement ce jugement vous en
souvenez yves michaud oui mais alors
justement d'abord je considère que c'est
pas au juge de prendre des décisions
aussi aussi complot complexe j'irai
qu'on pourrait mettre en cause aussi
aujourd'hui je veux dire l'ensemble du
processus judiciaire y compris avec les
instances comme les hautes autorités
françaises mais aussi les autorités
internationales et les cours de justice
européenne donc là il ya le dire et il
ya une sorte de galimatias juridique qui
fait que au fond pratiquement toutes les
thèses peuvent être défendus soutenu et
argumentée questions préliminaires de
constitutionnalité et c'est bon vous
serez plus sensibles et serait d'accord
avec vous c'est effectivement il y à des
phénomènes de déviance et de résistance
lorsque le système démocratique
dysfonctionne mais cela dit il ya déjà
un phénomène de
fait du direct résistance n'est passive
qui consiste à tout simplement voter
avec ses pieds ce qui me frappe c'est zé
s'en aller on a en gros si vous regardez
compte tenu de la crise du coc vide dans
pratiquement toutes les municipalités
françaises sauf les tout petit je veux
dire les gens ont été élus avec 20 20
pour cent de ses passes en valais c'est
pas émigrer dans sa 90 voter que
celle-ci ne plus participer à la vie
politique ça c'est une forme je dirais
de résistance
cinéma qui n'a rien
mais qui fonctionne en fait alors cela
dit c'est vrai que à partir du moment où
on a une complication extrême de la vie
sociale et politique avec toute
prolifération normes et puis deux on a
un système politique qui n'arrivent plus
à prendre en compte c'est la diversité
et surtout qu'ils n'arrivent plus à yahr
hiérarchisés en quelque sorte les
énormes à ce moment là bas effectivement
les gens sains pour impose mais c'est
pas une imposent leur résistance mais
c'est pas non violent à ce moment là
c'est pas du taureau injustement on va
pas au fond des bois et les gilets
jaunes se sont imposés par est sûre fait
entendre ils ont obtenu quelque chose
par la violence on veut dire des choses
comme elles sont mais on pourrait dire
d'un point de vue strictement légaliste
que dans une démocratie on a la
possibilité de s'exprimer de toute façon
de manifester son mécontentement
on a la possibilité de voter pour
changer de gouvernement et pour changer
la loi donc à partir de ce moment là on
est tenu de respecter la loi
effectivement on par solidarité on peut
avoir envie de faire entrer des migrants
innocent francis dans notre pays mais
s'il se révèle que l'un d'entre eux est
un terroriste à ce moment là qu'est ce
qu'on fait
le légaliste vous dira s'ils s'étaient
passés par par le par la frontière comme
tout le monde on aurait regardé son
passeport il l'aurait peut-être arrêter
dont vous êtes complices mais le
légaliste déjà répondra que le droit est
une chose vivante est une chose mouvante
et c'est pas simplement que la
rhétorique de vous dire cela mais
finalement vous disiez que c'était pas
forcément au juge de fixer ses limites
sauf qu'en réalité c'est parce que dit
le droit positif et se dire que pendant
longtemps en droit pénal on appliquer un
principe qui figure toujours d'ailleurs
dans le code pénal qui est celui de
l'indifférence des mobiles c'est-à-dire
qu'elle que soit finalement le mobile de
votre en traction le juge se dit moi je
ne le prends pas en considération
sauf que rapidement on s'est rendu
compte notamment dans le cadre de
l'application de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
que il y avait aussi tout une infusion
de notre droit interne par ces nouveaux
droits qui sont des droits
conventionnels et sur des questions de
résistance vous avez par exemple les
femen où on se poser la question de
savoir s'il y avait derrière une
démarche politique et si ça devait pas
être pris en considération si on était
resté à une application stricte du droit
on se serait dit effectivement
indifférence des mobiles on ne prend pas
en considération la démarche politique
livre des recours qui ont été faits la
cour de cassation a tranché il ya
maintenant quelques années en
reconnaissant qu'il y avait une démarche
politique qui devait ce n'était pas
juste de l'exhibitionnisme n'était pas
juste d'exeption c'est qu'il fallait
prendre en considération la démarche
politique et on voit bien que lorsque
c'est la cour de cassation qui reconnaît
la nécessité de prendre en considération
la démarche politique on voit bien que
on va quand on confie qu'elle est au
juge précisément un pouvoir de juger du
comportement qui peut être qualifié de
désobéissant et là c'est vrai qu'on
retombe dans la subjectivité mais au
moins cette subjectivité n'est pas
uniquement le fait des possibles auteurs
d'infractions mais est aussi le fait du
magistrat qui va pouvoir précisément
faire une balance équilibre est ce
qu'ils les fassent a déjà un acte
légitime un acte d'intérêt général etc
notamment la question qui s'est posée
pour les décrocheurs de portraits c'est
ce que va reconnaître la cour de
cassation en disant qu'il ya un
caractère d'intérêt général c'est de la
liberté d'expression et on voit bien que
le juge par conséquent ils se retrouvent
aussi juge de cette proportionnalité ils
se retrouvent juge de cette application
donc je pense que non moi je veux je ne
suis pas tellement d'accord non le fait
de dire que ça n'appartient pas au juge
au contraire je pense que précisément
les juges doivent faire preuve de
désobéissance et doivent s'emparer de
ces sujets parce qu'on le voit depuis
ces dernières années vous avez un
ensemble de mobilisation dans son de
protestation qui échoue précisément
devant les magistrats parce que il ya
une incapacité politique à pouvoir leur
répondre donc on dise larmes coercitives
tout simplement pour pouvoir endiguer
aussi certains mouvements de
protestation alors à partir de quel
moment as principe une cause est elle
supérieure à la loi
je veux dire si vous placez de manière
strictement éthique dire n'importe si
c'est votre convictions éthiques que la
loi est illégitime il faut vous en
dossier les responsabilités que vous
preniez vos responsabilités bon c'était
le cas par exemple des les objecteurs de
conscience je veux dire à l'époque où il
y avait un service militaire obligatoire
justement je m'en étais beaucoup occupé
dans les années 70 au moment où il y
avait le service militaire obligatoire
on a admis on a créé un statut
d'objecteur de conscience pour que ceux
qui ne voulaient pas pratiquer la
violence un éventuellement puisse
néanmoins faire un service civil veut
dire bon ça c'est un cas possible
maintenant moi je me méfie beaucoup des
convictions et puis alors dit je dirais
que ce qui me gêne beaucoup aujourd'hui
c'est il ya deux choses qui me gêne
pendant d'un côté le gouvernement des
juges et d'autre part beaucoup plus
généralement et là c'est pas c'est plus
et plus
des juges je parle mais beaucoup plus
qu'on est dans un régime politique au
mois en france qui est un régime je
dirais qu'au xviiie siècle on aurait on
aurait qualifié de despotique c'est à
dire le pouvoir exécutif en fait fait
les lois à travers les majorité godillot
d'ailleurs dès qu'il ya un problème
politique on dit qu'on va faire une loi
alors ça n'a abouti d'une part à la
complication de la vie juridique d'une
manière exceptionnelle si vous regardez
vous êtes encore plus experts que moi là
dessus si vous regardez la sédimentation
des réglementations en matière donc
d'une certaine manière tout tout et
arguments table de et deuxièmement donc
là je veux dire il ya un vrai mois je
souhaiterais un régime en france où il
ya d'une part un exécutif qui exécutent
qui agissent par exemple qui qui
écrivent les décrets d'application et
qu'ils fassent attention aux circulaires
d'application
dialyse parce qu'au fond dans l'arsenal
judiciaire en france il ya vraiment bien
de quoi traiter beaucoup beaucoup de
choses actuellement dans la loi je veux
dire et puis en même temps avoir une
majorité parlementaire qui légifèrent
mais qui légifère pas entièrement de
courant des courroies de transmission à
l'exécutif au xviiie siècle la confusion
du pouvoir exécutif du pouvoir
législatif ce soit chez montesquieu mais
chez tout le monde chez volnay c'était
caractéristique du régime mahométan et
c'était des régimes despotiques et
justement toute la révolution elle s'est
faite justement pour qu'ils aient plus
ce type de d'esprit ça les a pas empêché
ensuite de deux dérivés a allègrement
bon il ya déjà cet aspect là et puis
ensuite il ya effectivement je dirais la
complication de notre société ça ce
mouvement aussi bien en terme de
communauté que de provenance des
citoyens on est de culture de d'ethnie
de religion différente beaucoup de
communautés donc effectivement ça
nécessite je dirais beaucoup de normes
ou beaucoup normes qui ce qui en entrant
en jeu en conflit qui s'ajuste plus ou
moins et effectivement ça conduire la
juge issia risation et je dirai au
pouvoir aussi bien des juges que vous
pouvoir des avocats je veux dire
moi il ya une chose qui me fait beaucoup
rire actuellement on ne rend pas trop
compte dans la presse mais on est en
train de juger la fraude fiscale de mme
du baron seillière et et de ses acolytes
et c'est pas une petite fraude fiscale
c'est des centaines de millions ça a
commencé en 2007
l affaire c'est ça vient justice en 2022
qui ne sais pas si vous voyez donc ça
veut pas dire que la justice est lente
ça veut dire qu'ils les moyens de la
faire fonctionner et dysfonctionné sont
sur d'innombrables et ça c'est vous et
vos collègues respectifs des experts va
tout ça est dire donc on sait aussi
comment faire prospérer comme vous dites
souvent on faisait comment faire
prospérer des causes qui sont plus ou
moins litigieuses ou qui sont plus ou
moins discutable je n'ai même pas de
lait condamnable mais qui sont et qui
sont les discutable enfin il faudrait
mieux en discuter d il ya deux choses
qui vont pas du tout aujourd'hui en
france et d'une part cette cette dérive
despotique du pouvoir on le voit très
bien à toutes les réglementations qu'a
prise le gouvernement en matière de kobe
de même sous la pression de l'urgence et
avec la méconnaissance qu'on avait de la
situation puis d'autre part la juridique
judiciarisation de la société
on viendra si vous devez bien on
reviendra sur le pouvoir et ilinykh ou
pas parce que c'est un des grands
arguments en faveur de la règle qui
limite le pouvoir parce qu'on le
considère comme tel c'est qu'à 5/6 et
qui dysfonctionne mais avant ça je vais
vous poser les questions parce que
respecter la loi dans le monde tous les
bons citoyens c'était quelqu'un qui
respectait la loi mais aujourd'hui on
nous dit qu'il ya des valeurs il faut
aussi respecter les valeurs ça devient
beaucoup plus compliqué à partir du
moment où effectivement on est comme
vous le disiez une société extrêmement
disparates personne n'a les mêmes
valeurs on n'a pas la même culture et
parfois même on vit dans des réalités
qui n'ont plus rien à voir
c'est encore c'est pour ça aussi que je
suis très gêné je suis très soupçonneux
sur sur les mobiles il ya une chose qui
m'a beaucoup frappé que ce soit pour le
procès des des du bataclan où que ce
soit pour le procès de nordahl le
landais on commence par la personnalité
des gens de sa direction les modèles ça
c'est ça oui mais c'est ça qui va pas
déclarer moi je m'attends quand piris
tout ce qui m'intéresse et qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait après on verra si on
peut trouver une explication à ce qu'ils
en fait certains syndicats vous diront
justement que c'est un pauvre un
problème de commencer par personnel là
bas je pense que c'est un vrai problème
patrice après juge déjà que l'on peut
expliquer et et on supplie quasiment ces
pauvres aux assassins ont les supplie de
dire que en fait il était de bonne foi
et c'était au nom de leur valeur en
quelques matches il va leur permettre si
les trouve très bizarre mais c'est pas
dissociable nights est indissociable de
l'intimé conviction en france on peut
vous condamner parce qu'on a l'intime
convient la coupable donc la
psychologisation du jeu l'excusé est
fondamental
c'est pas seulement la france et qu'on
est offert dans une société où en
psychologie la mort
ça on vous dit d'aller voir un psy un
donc
non mais après effectivement il ya la
part d'intimé conviction et après il ya
ce sont les pressions de la
personnalisation de la chaîne et pour le
coup dans le cas de la personnalisation
des peines on peut prendre en compte de
fait la personnalité mais aussi les
mobiles de l'acte est par exemple dans
les dents légère dans les procès
terroriste typiquement il n'y a pas non
plus d'indifférence des mobiles puisque
le mobile terroriste va être pris en
considération comme étant un facteur
aggravant donc ça dépend la manière dont
on voit finalement cette question la
personnalisation parce que cibler
lorsqu'on les enfin lorsque certains
s'expriment mais c'est plus dit elle
s'exprime non pas enfin ils sont presque
leurs propres ennemis dans le cadre de
leur défense mais on voit bien que ça
peut être aussi être commandé à sion
contre eux c'est pas forcément dans une
volonté subjective de clémence ou de
bienveillance de la part de la part des
juridictions alors revenons à notre à
notre sujet comment faites vous
justement aujourd'hui où il suffit plus
de respecter la loi pour être un bon
citoyen il faut en plus épouser les
valeurs de la république alors même que
la république n'a jamais été là jamais
été habité par autant de gens différents
qui n'ont plus rien à voir les uns avec
les autres qui ne regarde pas les mêmes
programmes de télévision qui n'écoutent
pas la même musique qui ne lisent pas
les mêmes journaux qui parlent pas
forcément la même langue qui sont pas
nés tous dans ce pays qui ne partagent
donc pas les mêmes valeurs mais parfois
même keane qui vivent dans des réalités
totalement alternative il ya des
réalités alternatives effectivement il
ya un éclatement un éclatement des
causes il ya un éclatement des
convictions mais je pense que justement
c'est aussi l'appréciation judiciaire de
ce que peut être l'acte légitime de
désobéissance et pour ça je pense qu'il
ya des ya un peu des boussoles c'est la
boussole de la proportionnalité de
l'acte en fonction de la finalité est ce
que c'est une finalité d'intérêt général
est ce que c'est une fille d'intérêt
général qui bascule elle même parfois
dans une forme de haine dans des formes
de discrimination donc tout ça doit être
doit être pris en considération par par
les auditions mais je pense que c'est
essentiel je viens de tout le temps de
tout temps il ya toujours eu des normes
qu'on considérait comme étant des nomes
obsolète et on sait qu'il a fallu des
résistances virons souvient du combat
qu'il était porté par gisèle halimi on
se souvient de ces législations qui
empêchait l'avortement et on voit bien
que aujourd'hui ce qui nous paraît avec
le recul avec plusieurs années comme si
je peux dire s'imposer de façon presque
universel mais pourtant ça ne se faisait
pas lorsque vous aviez aussi des
initiations qui récriminer les
homosexuels c'est pareil dans le jir
dans le code pénal des infractions
pénales donc on voit bien qu'il ya aussi
une évolution de la société que cette
évolution de la société elle
s'accompagne pas toujours immédiatement
d'une évolution législative et parfois
il faut forcer cette évolution négative
on parlait tout à l'heure de la des
personnes qui venaient en aide aux
personnes en situation irrégulière il a
fallu aussi le combat qui a été mené par
cédric airs ou par sa défense pour
pouvoir exercer débat de recours et ceux
retrouvés jusque devant le conseil
communal où le conseil conscience
reconnaît comme principe avaient leurs
consignes elle le principe de fraternité
et pourtant vous voyez bien que le point
de départ de tout ça c'était un acte de
désobéissance mai je pense que le
principe de fraternité nous dit beaucoup
plus universellement et nous dit plus
dans la manière dont nous devrons agir
dans la collectivité plutôt que le délit
en lui-même de répression de la
solidarité lorsque et récrimine aussi
bien des personnes qui le font par
conviction politique que il peut
réprimer aussi des personnes qui sont
des réseaux de passeurs et qui le font à
des fins exclusivement financière donc
c'est vrai que c'est un débat qui est
extrêmement compliqué c'est un débat qui
est compliqué parce qu'il ya beaucoup
aussi personnes qui se revendique de la
désobéissance mais justement c'est aussi
cette appréciation à faire part par la
justice et cette appréciation à faire
aussi d'une station du paradoxe qu'on
peut sauver parce que on se rejoint sur
le fait que la démocratie aujourd'hui et
dans un étang qui fait que les
institutions sont presque dans cette
date fixe y perdant qui exige que les
citoyens réagissent et je pense de ce
point de vue que le simple fait de pas
participer au débat démocratique le fait
par exemple de voter blanc avec toutes
les questions d'ailleurs de la
comptabilisation du bulbe du vote blanc
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne plus ne
fonctionne plus précisément parce que ce
n'est pas suffisant et en plus on en
voit aussi et des riches parce que le
vote blanc permis aussi à certaines
personnes précisément des tribus sur la
base d'une minorité sont bénéficier
d'une majorité populaire donc avec tout
ce que cela entraîne donc je pense que
si vous avez des institutions qui ne
sont plus capables de répondre à des
demandes citoyennes extrêmement forte et
bien de fait les désobéissants sont
parfois s'imposer et c'est aussi le cas
d'ailleurs en matière climatique les
militants d'extinction bellion
l'ensemble des actions qui peuvent être
faites aussi parce que il ya une
conviction que s'il n'y a pas des actes
forts le pouvoir politique ne réagira
pas et s'ils avaient pas eu précisément
ces actes de militantisme ci avait pas
eu aussi des recours entrepris notamment
dans la sphère du siècle formidable
recours devant les juridictions
administratives et bien le pouvoir
politique sait rester complètement
inerte restait impuissant face à ces
mouvements donc à la fois j'allais dire
complexité mais en même temps complexité
qui ne doit pas conduire à ce que on
criminalise les désobéissants au
prétexte précisément qui ne
respecteraient pas les normes parce
qu'il serait je pense profondément
erroné de considérer que toutes les
normes sont légitimes et de considérer
que précisément il n'ya pas des combats
qui doivent dépasser les normes et qui
doivent dépasser l'application de
certains articles notamment ce président
capitale réponse rapide michaud ont fait
une pause et conviendra d'accord pour le
fait sur le fait que la législation doit
doit évoluer et doit petit à petit
élaborer des jurisprudences mais en
revanche ce que je souhaiterais si vous
voulez c'est que justement dans un monde
où les tous les citoyens sont des gens
d'origines différentes on se réfère à
quelque principe très simple de la
république c'est ça mon avis la
simplicité de quelques principes on dit
fraternité mais il ya liberté mais on
peut assez facilement monnayer le
concept de liberté dans les buts et on
va leur accorder le cas des si on peut
le faire à des sorties passe sanitaire
en
liberté il ya égalité et et solidarité
moi je vous dirais préfère près
solidarité ou fraternité
mais il faut qu'il y ait un petit que ce
soit un tout petit nombre de normes si
vous voulez on a tellement de normes et
c'est tellement mal fichu que au fond on
sait plus à quoi on obéit moi c'est ça
que je que je mets en cause étaient du
coup ça permet à tout le monde de
revendiquer la possibilité de désobéir
et bien justement on va voir quelques
cas concrets notamment ceux ce convoi de
la liberté
juste après une pause
[Musique]
les banques vont elles vraiment bien
pouvons-nous avoir confiance en elles
sono la brique et à quel point ce
sentiment d'insécurité que nous pouvons
tous avoir été victime aujourd'hui les
banques ne sont pas des endroits où on
est plus en sécurité qu'on ne l'était en
2007 peu importe la connerie que la
banque d'affaires personne ne sera
jamais plus si je gérais une entreprise
d'une taille comme grandes banques
françaises sans les nommer de la même
manière on m'aurait fait déposer le
bilan déjà depuis des commandes à faire
alors pour protéger nos économies pour
ce qu'ils peuvent évidemment il faudrait
ceux des banques la risée mes parents ou
d'autres personnes qui ont dit milou
15000 euros sur leur contrat ils vont où
ils peuvent aller acheter des delors
elle est achetée de une autre monnaie
aujourd'hui c'est eux des banques à
reese et ben non pour faire que les
courses au super u il me faut ma carte
qui me font mon compte donc sur la masse
globale les tout petits pourront pas
bougé
[Musique]
vous avez lancé des appels à la
mobilisation notamment pour pour bloquer
des ponts mais vous avez été arrêtés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai été
arrêté pour complot incitations d'un
acte criminel et terroriste
c'est pas la première fois qu au québec
un bon arrêt débloquer mais dans les
mesures que nous sommes en ce moment
sanitaire est très autoritaire du
gouvernement
je crois qu'ils ont voulu démordre et
qu'ils avaient la force d'autorité il ya
une volonté aussi peut-être de
discréditer tous tous ces mouvements
anti mesures sanitaires ont savent
rahman mis à l'écart ici au québec et au
canada
tristesse d'avoir un débat public
[Musique]
on reprend d'autres débats sur la
désobéissance civile avec vincent
brengard qui est avocat et qui publie
avec le journaliste jérôme hourdeaux
chez fayard revendiquons le droit à la
désobéissance et yves michaud qui est
philosophe c'est l'auteur de citoyenneté
et loyauté et beaucoup d'ouvragés sur la
violence et la violence politique en
particulier yves michaud alors quelques
cas contraire concret on parle beaucoup
de ce convoi de la liberté à la fois qui
bloque la ville de t'avoir au canada
mais qui s'est lancé en france
aujourd'hui et qui est censé
parvenir à paris vendredi soir à vitesse
réduite
dans l'hypothèse de pouvoir bloquer les
capitales alors là on est dans un cas de
liberté c'est une manifestation la
liberté c'est c'est quoi lassé de la 2 e
bay licence si tenté que ça parvienne à
ses fins mais vous la voyez comment vous
non comme une communauté station
collectif de protestation contre les
normes sanitaires après on verra si
c'est désobligeant en fonction du verre
du du mode emprunté est ce que
d'ailleurs il va y avoir des
contraventions est ce qu'il va y avoir
des comportements qui pourraient être
qualifiés mais qualifiable pénalement
mais en tout cas je pense que on est en
plein coeur de la protestation est en en
plein coeur de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure par rapport aux défaillances des
institutions représentatives de se dire
que sur une pratique comme celle du pass
vaccinable clairement il ya eu des
manquements des manquements dans le
débat démocratique c'était un débat
démocratique qui était imposé par le
pouvoir exécutif selon ses propres
règles notamment avec systématiquement
le recours à des procédures accélérées
qui ont presque empêché le parlement de
pouvoir débattre le pouvoir contesté et
d'ailleurs non seulement vous avez dsp
procédure accélérée et puis vous avez
aussi des aspects purement techniques
moi je n'ai toujours pas compris comment
est ce que le parlement peut questionner
l'action gouvernementale à partir du
moment où par exemple n'est pas doté de
son propre conseil scientifique et que
le conseil scientifique et celui avec
notamment un président nommé par présent
l'appliquent ça pose des questions
purement mallet se charge de vous
interrompre vincent mais là on voit une
photo c'est au canada au canada ils
n'ont pas de ils fonctionnent pas de la
même manière qu'eux nous et il ya la
même eu la même le même mouvement de
protestation et on en a vu en allemagne
on en a vu ici et là ça n'est pas lié
aux institutions elles-mêmes c'est lié
au fait qu'à un moment nous dit aux gens
c'est comme ça et pas autrement
verrait soit vous faire vacciner soit le
sortir impasse et la réaction est la
même mais je pense que chaque pays a ses
particularités parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de pays dans lequel est pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de convoi de la liberté non
plus et des pays d'ailleurs pour
lesquelles il peut y avoir une
vaccination obligatoire donc ça
interroge aussi la manière dans
certaines démocraties dans son
gouvernement ont pu imposer la
vaccination sans se retrouver avec des
contestations populaires plus ou moins
forte mais après c'est sûr que le
dénominateur commun sans parler de nos
singularités
institutionnels c'est évidemment un
profond sentiment de lassitude après
deux ans ou presque vécu sous l'
exception avec une accumulation de
normes extrêmement contraignant des
demandes devenir de plus en plus fortes
à l'égard des citoyens et la conviction
qui est de plus en plus forte aussi à
travers le variant au micron que ce qui
a été mis en oeuvre peut-être été
nécessaire certes un certain moment mais
on peut pas toujours utiliser les mêmes
arguments lorsqu'on est notamment face à
des variants qui ne répondent pas aux
mêmes règles ou en tout cas qui ont des
phénomènes top 6 pour ce qui concerne
par exemple la contamination on sait par
exemple que le banian micron n'a pas la
même virulence n'a pas la même n'a pas
la même virulence et surtout que la
vaccination n'a pas du tout les mêmes
effets concernant la virulence donc on
n'est pas sur un même débat ni
scientifique ni en termes de
proportionnalité dans les atteintes qui
sont portées aux libertés individuelles
que lorsque on était soit en matière de
confinement soit en matière de deux
passes sanitaires et non pas parce
vaccinale invention moi je n'entre pas
du tout dans cette argumentation parce
que je considère que cette affaire du
coc vide et au micron compris c'était
une affaire extrêmement
giraud pas qu'au départ même le conseil
scientifique pour il se trouve que
j'avais organisé dans le temps
l'universite tous les savoirs même la
composition du conseil scientifique de
macron était tout à fait discutable mais
en fait on ne savait pas trop où on
allait j'avoue que lorsqu'il ya eu la
déclaration du premier confinement
j'aurais incliné à penser et j'aurais
impayable souhaité que au fond macro
invoqua l'article 16 des délires la
suspension parce que la situation était
une situation qui était dramatique on
savait pas où on allait on était dans le
brouillard on l'est beaucoup moins mais
je veux dire on a de la chance je veux
dire d'être beaucoup moins dans le lin
est effectivement toute décision prise
était contestable je crois qu'il ya des
moments où en politique on peut prendre
des décisions d'urgence je veux dire
avec une durée limitée bien évidemment
un contrôle a posteriori pas forcément à
priori mais a posteriori et de
responsabilité et pas seulement devant
la cour de justice de la république
cette bonne blague mais un contrôle de
l'action politique il ya des moments où
c'est pour ça que j'ai trouvé que toutes
ces discussions autour du pass and i ter
de l'obligation vaccinale des étais été
très largement ou deux parce que c'était
un cas d'urgence celui du reiki et dans
les cas d'urgence on peut pas tout peut
pas tout maîtriser on peut pas suivre
toutes les procédures et on peux pas
faut pas faire semblant de suivre les
procédures on n'en n'a pas suivi mais
dans le cas de l'article 16 au sus pour
les libertés publiques la cantine quand
il ya un problème de salut public est là
c'est pour le en l'occurrence salut
public c'était vraiment un salut public
c'était quand même une épidémie grave
avec quand même pas mal de morts à la
clé
il ya un système sanitaire qui était au
bordel enfin vous comprenez bien que ça
aussi ça se discute
vous êtes des gens vous dire non non ce
pas une épidémie grave c'est pas mal
réussi c'est peu mais c'est facile de le
dire maintenant mais je vais aller porte
les ricains pas vous dire où vous auriez
eu beaucoup de gens qui auraient eu qui
se serait senti tout à fait justifiée à
se révolter consulte pas au repos leurs
entreprises que ça je sais pas si sûr
c'est bien sûr parce que je veux dire
quand il ya un cas vraiment de d'urgence
et de drame national bon je comprends
bien que dans les sociétés heureuse
facile où on est deux ans de
restrictions de mazamet papa la boîte de
nuit etc on le savait pas il croyait
qu'il y aurait pourtant ce soit
insupportable
je veux bien mais en même temps je dis
il ya des moments où dans la vie dans la
vie politique et sociale il faut prendre
des décisions qui sont difficiles
maintenant on voit bien que on peut
toujours dire que l'obligation vaccinale
face à la je dirais qu aux côtés bénin
finalement dû marion au micron elle est
sûre elle est sûrement discret civisme
on pense que l on le sait cette
sélection c'est pas avant mais je mets
jules mais justement je pense que par
rapport à ce que vous disiez sur les sur
les pieds son article 16 effectivement
on a pas eu d'explication l'article 16
avant on parlait mais le premier décret
qui avait été pris par boney m on ne
l'avait pas été sur ce fondement mais
sur le fond non des circonstances
exceptionnelles c'est une théorie jeu
exponentielle qui permet dans certains
cas de porter
déclaré l'état d'urgence je veux dire le
gouverneur mais je détiens d'urgence je
pense que les jeux je pense que le
combat de la liberté et des
contestations à noël roger
que je pense je pense que dans dans la
manière dont c'est l'état d'urgence
sanitaire était décrétée en france avait
assez peu de voix qui s'est levé pour
dire que au départ il n'y avait pas
besoin précisément d'une réaction des
pouvoirs public précisément besoin veut
dire dans l'est ce concert exceptionnel
aussi de pouvoir réagir la question
c'est celle de l'évolution des
circonstances et c'est de se dire que en
dépit de cette évolution des
circonstances on répond encore par des
normes qui sont complètement
contraignante et que le débat
démocratique n'a pas évolué lorsque vous
avez sur la question de l'efficacité du
vaccin
je suis pas scientifique je regarde
simplement par exemple l'étude d'impact
qui avait accompagné le dernier deux
derniers projets de loi et on constate
qu'il ya une affirmation par le pouvoir
législatif que le le vaccin s'il a un
effet concernant les cas grave n'a pas
d'effet pour pouvoir limiter la
contamination donc si vous rendez la
vaccination obligatoire forcément que
dans le contrôle de proportionnalité
vous devez
serment pendant considération ce
changement de configuration parce que si
vous ne prenez pas en compte ce
changement de configuration finalement
cela revenir à avoir presque un contrôle
opéré par le conseil concerne ou par le
conseil d'état qui sera systématiquement
presque a priori il n'ya pas rentrer
dans le détail de la réalité de ces
normes et de la réalité des objectifs
qu'elles poursuivent donc moi je suis
pas du tout en train de dire qu' il
n'aurait pas fallu prendre je dire de
mesures exceptionnelles je dis
simplement que l'on n'a pas forcément
permis le débat
si ça pouvait justifier au départ parce
qu'on était face à une urgence
complètement exceptionnel ça se justifie
beaucoup moins maintenant après deux ans
de crise et on nous dit sur notamment
sur l'adoption du dernier texte
procédure accélérée on laisse près de
deux semaines au parlement pour pouvoir
discuter du texte et en plus on prévoit
déjà la date d'application et d'entrer
en vigueur du pass vaccinale alors même
que le parlement n'a pas commencé à
débattre et j'entends bien ce que vous
dites mais parce que j'aime être en
cause c'est la technocratie et la
bureaucratie française c'est la maladie
de faire des circulaires de nous faire
signer une autorisation de sortie etc
mais pourquoi j'ai parlé d'articles 16
parce que finalement une des erreurs du
pouvoir ça a été de soute de de vouloir
je dirais de ne pas affirmer la
dangereuse et caractère dangereux de la
situation dès le début on proposait pas
le mot de confinement on disait pas il y
avait fallait pas mettre de masse qu'il
fallait rien du tout je veux dire au
début on avait je pense qu'il faut dans
ces cas là et la psychologie elle compte
je veux dire il fallait dire aux gens
mais attendez c'est une situation qui
est grave il fallait le dire tout de
suite c'est peut-être qu'ils ne
l'avaient pas véritablement rêve c'est
là où la responsabilité politique on
écoute et on s'est beaucoup moqué de
bachelot qui avait conquis avait
commandé des millions et des milliards
de masques contre le
le
navire est cnra dans la chambre
finalement il s'est rien passé on a fui
dans les masques à la poubelle et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a nommé ministre
mais c'est vrai que j'ai à dire est que
en fait est là elle avait agi de manière
à peu près correct de dire il faut pas
sur mais bon il faut bien il faut pas
sûr sous-estimer les situations et puis
ensuite alors pour ça c'est le problème
français je veux dire c'est dès qu'un
dès qu'il ya un énarque et
moi j'ai été sidéré de découvrir que il
y avait des agences régionales de santé
dans today dans toutes les régions y
avait une alliance régionale de santé et
puis santé france je sais pas quoi qu'il
y avait des agences de toutes les sortes
mais ça c'est l'habitude française de
nous mettre 1 1 une sorte de
millefeuille de 2 est la caractéristique
d'une panique organisationnel comme
celle qu'on a que c'est justement vous
rajoute un conseil de défense qui coûte
au dessus et dans conseils de
scientifiques exactement les zones où
les conseils qu'on a déjà lancé me gêne
aussi c'est que l'êta en france aussi
se décharge de ses responsabilités
fortes
sur des tas d agences et sur des os de
l'autorité moi j'aimerais bien savoir
guerre une statue d'une haute autorité
comme défenseur des droits normalement
le défenseur des droits c'est le
magistrat d'un côté et puis c'est là le
pouvoir législatif de l'autre et je vois
pas pourquoi il ya besoin de monsieur
toubon ou je ne sais qui et qui devient
défenseur des droits parce qu'on a jugé
qu'il était nécessaire de le retrouver
une sinécure et puis alors à ce moment
là et parce que c'est un peu ça une
autre autorité nathan le défenseur ou la
défenseuse des droits parce que c'est
une femme aujourd'hui on peut pas dire
que l'actuel mais le même discours que
les juges ou que les députés et
justement je veux dire et alors je dirai
quelle est sa légitimité c'est qu'elles
défendent et
c'est pas parce que et c'est pas parce
qu'on vous nomme ça veut dire que vous
savez faire des chaussures excuser parce
qu'elles ont fait justement ça ces deux
autorités administratives indépendantes
indépendante avec des normes qui sont
nommés maintenir alors je pour le coup
elles ont elles ont pu rendre vous
faisiez tout à la référence à jacques
toubon elles ont pu rendre des avis des
recommandations extrêmement fort nous
allons d'ailleurs sur les questions de
violences policières ou ou d'autres qui
sont essentiels au débat démocratique
par exemple sncd h sur la question du du
projet de loi en matière de payzac
signal on dit attention à la question de
la proportionnalité attention aussi à la
question du contrôle des citoyens dans
les restaurants attention aussi à
prendre en considération une politique
publique globale notamment sur la
question des lits d'hôpitaux parce que
les lits dans les hôpitaux ça a été
utilisé aujourd'hui dans le canot aussi
de l'étude d'impact pour dire qu' il y
avait eu une surpression hospitalière
qui devait me conduire à se faire à se
faire vacciner sauf qu'en fait ça fait
déjà enfin ça fait plusieurs mois que la
cncd gêne évidemment mais il faut le
prendre en considération je pense que
non cncdh défenseur danois ont un rôle
fondamental mais la difficulté c'est
précisément je suis d'accord mais si on
ne saisit pas si on les écoute pas et je
suis d'accord avec vous mais j'ai en
fait plus un problème je dirais
d'organisations françaises et de
complications bureaucratiques française
je pense que la simplicité angélique
voudrait que encore une fois entre le
magistrat et puis le législateur ça
suffise je ne vois pas pourquoi on a
besoin en plus de nommer des ddd de 20
en charge de dunes de tout tout tout les
problèmes possibles et imaginables avec
des hautes autorités qui sont nommés
à discrétion la plupart du temps dans la
discrétion il faut je pense d'ailleurs
que c'est une bonne réforme de l'état
consisterait à toutes les supprimer des
unes après les autres yves michaud au
nom de la sécurité moi je suis
libertariens aussi de ce côté là mais
j'ai planté en france ce qui me laisse
qui menace la liberté c'est la
bureaucratie mais c'est donc grâce à la
sécurité ou à la santé
les deux mots se ressemblent je pense
qu'ils ont même d'avoir une technologie
commune est là c'est qu'il fasse de la
sécurité la santé qui le sont devenus de
simples même combat aujourd'hui un de la
part des gouvernements et des autorités
comment peut-on supposer c'est à dire
comment peut-on aujourd'hui aux et
invoquer sa liberté face à des mots
d'ordre qui ont vocation à justement à
supprimer toutes les libertés au nom de
la sécurité et au nom de la santé on
peut du jour au lendemain supprimez
toutes nos libertés etc ont trouvé
qu'une bonne partie de la population
trouve cela justifié
comment s'y opposer est-ce qu'on a
encore le moyen de dire mais non ma
liberté c'est plus important où la
liberté pas seulement la mienne mais
celle des partis là bas la liberté c'est
plus important que la sécurité où c'est
plus important que la santé on voit bien
que c'est devenu impossible sur le sur
le plan de la santé le jour à évoquer
votre liberté est foutu oui mais
frédéric moi je suis je pense qu'une
clarification de base des
responsabilités devrait suffire ch se
trouve quand même déjà bizarre ne
serait-ce que l'intitulé du ministère et
du ministère de la solidarité de la
santé je me suis aussi à l'occasion de
cette crise comme comme il y avait des
communiqués tout le temps à la radio
puis j'attendais que c'était ministère
la solidarité de la santé moi je veux
bien mais je crois qu'à ministère de la
santé qui s'occuperait de la santé ça
serait déjà pas mal il n'a pas en plus à
s'occuper de la solidarité de la
bienveillance des mobiles dirait bien
que c'est l'essai c'est la sécurité
sociale qui est là c'est qu'il
solidarité en france on est dans un jeu
d'api multi le monde mutualiste
lhérisson retour tout est mutualisé et à
la fin vous vous êtes obligé de vous
payer une mutuelle parce qu'en plus
c'est vrai
j'ai dit j'ai plus de mutuelle parce que
je trouve que c'est scandaleux mais en
même temps je vois bien qu'il ya plus de
sécurité sociale non plus sauf si vous
sauf si vous êtes au dernier degré de
l'agonie non là on est très bien couvert
en france quand on va mourir
malheureusement on aimerait découvrir
passant je pense qu'il y assez peu de
personnes aujourd'hui qui défendent une
vision complètement maximaliste liberté
est ce dire sans limites sans
possibilité d'avoir l'air aussi parfois
des dérogations compte tenu des
circonstances exceptionnelles la
question s'est posée face à une menace
terroriste notamment poste attentats de
novembre 2015 où il a fallu adapter
notre arsenal législatif il a fallu
repenser aussi le droit je devrais le
droit d'exception président pour pouvoir
répondre à cette situation on l'a aussi
repenser au moment de la crise sanitaire
mais même si on n'a pas de vision mais
maximaliste
tout le débat est encore celui de la
proportionnalité c'est à se demander si
les atteintes et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
fait le conseil d'état c'est ce que fait
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
lorsque l on à connaître notamment de
l'obligation du port du masque et
prennent en considération les données
scientifiques les atteintes qui sont
portés notamment à la liberté d'aller et
venir à la liberté de circuler à la
liberté d'entreprendre et elle se
demande si ces atteintes sont justifiées
au regard de la finalité mais la sq est
dans la grosse levée le conseil d'état
vient de retoquer la décision du préfet
de police de paris de rétablir
l'obligation du masque en extérieur ouf
enfin pendant six ou sept mois on a
porté le masque en extérieur tout le
monde sa mais enfin dans une minute
scientifique personne ne vous aurais dit
que ça va quoi que ce soit mais le
conseil d'état n'a pas réagi et si les
individus avaient refusé de porter leur
masque que n'aurait-on pas
dire c'est irresponsable c'est ça ça va
être bien qu'on a passé désobéissance à
au final parce que beaucoup de personnes
en fait on attendu aussi cette décision
du conseil d'état pourrait décider de ne
plus porter mais je pense d'ailleurs que
la question du vin du du port du masque
pour moi justement est l'illustration si
je peux dire des limites aussi du
contrôle juridictionnel parce que on
voit qu'en fait si un contrôle est
intervenu notamment de la part du
conseil d'état il était que dans les cas
les plus manifestes wierre heureusement
que les juridictions administratives
nous dit que si dans une rue déserte
vous avez pas vous protéger de vous même
je veux bien mais bon si on doit porter
un masque en permanence ça fait quelque
chose quand même d'assez ubuesque d'une
certaine façon mais tout le reste ont
des recours on voit qu'en fait le
contrôle ap véritablement été fait nous
on avait on avait initié un recours
notamment sur la question des fermetures
de théâtre c'était en décembre en
décembre 2001 on arrive devant le
conseil d'état en disant au moment même
où vous aviez les centres commerciaux
qui était ouvert et d'ailleurs il
suffisait d'aller voir le week-end pour
voir les files d'attentes de personnes
devant les centres commerciaux mais en
revanche on a considéré avec les mêmes
données scientifiques que la fermeture
des théâtres s'imposait toujours alors
même qu on leur appliquait des jauges
extrêmement limité de personnes qui
pouvaient accéder au spectacle et
pourtant donc c'est pour ça que c'est
quand même le débat la professionnalité
parce que quand vous avez notamment des
lieux jr cultuelle ou en tout cas des
lieux ici de geiger de culture qui
appliquent de façon rigoureuse le
protocole qui leur est imposée
finalement on interdit mais que de
l'autre on permet par exemple
l'ouverture hier de deux magasins on
voit les limites auxquelles on se virent
on accède et d'ailleurs ces limites sont
d'autant plus notable que tous les
contrôles notamment opéré au sein de
l'union européenne ne sont pas sont pas
les mêmes et d'ailleurs en belgique en
décembre en décembre dernier le j'ai
considéré que la fermeture des lieux
théâtre était disproportionnée donc ça
montre bien que cette question de la
proportionnalité est aussi une question
philosophique mais aussi une question
importante dans la nécessité aussi que
les juges affirment leur indépendance
affirment leur courage face à des
mesures qui ne sont pas toujours
justifiées il m'a fait drôle dans la
sphère du conseil d'état parce que moi
j'ai lu ensuite monsieur l'allemand il a
repris sa circulaire et on avait le
droit de se balader dans la rue sans
masques sauf aux arrêts d'autobus tout
sauf dans les endroits où il ya une
queue sauf dans les marchés sauf dans
son sort en gros si vous étiez tout seul
au milieu du désert vous avez le droit
d'être sans masque je veux dire mais ça
ça renvoie pour celle qui sait peut-être
mais une petite manip chez moi mais je
vais dire ça renvoie au fait que en
france le pouvoir bureaucratique ne l'a
jamais ne la joue mais il revient
toujours par derrière alors est ce qu'il
faut en faire moi je pense qu'il faut
plutôt en faire une question de
sociologie une question qu une question
de droit que dire il ya un défaut de la
société française c'est vrai aussi ce
que vous avez dit c'est qu'il y avait
aussi une disparité en europe qui était
incroyable les choses étaient beaucoup
plus strict en espagne par exemple j'y
vais souvent les choses étaient beaucoup
plus strictes et mai en france non
c'était mais c'était c'était justement
réglementaire alors il y avait des tas
des cas avec d'état d'exception et puis
voilà je vais confinés sur la résistance
serait mieux parler d'autre chose comme
le convoi de la liberté parce que là
c'est dire s'ils étaient encore une fois
ce qui me gêne si vous voulez dans ces
histoires de passes vaccinale c'est que
on avait affaire à une situation où
scientifiquement savais pas trop où on
allait 1 et donc je comprends qu'il eut
des flottements mais dans le cadre du
droit à la désobéissance civile on
évoque souvent le côté non violent
d'être désobéissance civile et vous
justement vous avez écrit pour dire
qu'au fond la résistance non violente
elle fait de plus en plus chargées de
violents exactement c'est ça le problème
c'est à dire que vous avez voulu dire
normalement une manifestation c'est le
cas en espagne je veux dire c'est le cas
bien sûr en angleterre et aux etats-unis
une manifestation c'est sur les
trottoirs vous n'avez pas interdire
parce que vous manipulez avait le droit
de manifester vos idées mais vous n'avez
pas interdire aux ions la circulation
c'est ce qui va se passer et que ce
qu'on voit des libertés chaque fois
qu'on fait un nom en bloc tout le monde
bon bah oui je dire on manifeste qu'on
est en alors une dimension fondamentale
dans cette affaire-là si aujourd'hui
c'est la médiatisation bien évidemment
parce que la violence permet de
justement de se montrer en même temps je
dire il ya des techniques de contrôle de
la violence et un jeu hein je veux dire
la police met au point des techniques de
deux coups de contention en quelque
sorte de la violence mais du coup le
gdir la la la la la résistance civique
elle se joue devant avec tous ces
journalistes freelance qui sont au
milieu des des heures elle se joue je
dire médiatiquement je dirais c'est
peut-être alors c'est peut-être là que
ça donne un effet positif parce que la
société prend conscience je crois que si
on les gilet jaune s'il n'y avait pas eu
la violence suis pas sûr qu'on aurait
pris conscience de l'importance du
malaise de toute une partie de la
population française mais en même temps
il est bien vrai aussi que là on est
plus dans la résistance civique on est
dans la violence je dirais et jusqu où
elle va bon il a pas pour le moment elle
s'arrête parce que elle se limite pas ce
que tout le monde met au point des
techniques qui évite cela dit il ya
quand même des gens éborgné était même
des gens qui perdent des mains il ya
quand même des policiers qui sont
gravement blessés je veux dire c'est
s'est passé parce en coûte un bain sont
partiellement enfin partiellement
d'accord vous revoir papa véritablement
parce que déjà je mal j'ai du mal à
comprendre ce que enfin les
illustrations je dire de cette violence
qui s'expriment parce que si on
mentionne par exemple limitant
d'extinction rebellion les militants
écologistes justement ils sont aussi
formés à ces questions désobéissance
civile ils savent la manière dont on
peut éviter précisément l'application de
la loi les réseaux sociaux ont aussi
permis d'avoir des mouvements d
obéissance à travers le happening on l'a
vu d'ailleurs il n'ya pas très longtemps
avec le sosie de jean michel blanquer a
donc des airs des choses qui marchent et
qui fonctionne médiatiquement
extrêmement bien sans pour autant
recourir à la violence et les militantes
et militants antispécistes qui ont pu
s'introduire dans certains dans ces
élevages et non pas été violente à
l'égard des personnes qui les quittent
les diriger donc et pareil pour le
pareil pour le mouvement des jeunes je
pense pas que le mouvement des jeunes
par exemple puis se réduire à des actes
de violence qui ont pu qui ont pu les
payer et en plus il faudrait prendre en
considération aussi d'autres facteurs et
notamment la logique confrontation elle
qui peut exister entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants qui est là
aussi une singularité française qu'on
retrouve pas dans notre pays qu'ils
peuvent pratiquer par exemple ce qu'on
appelle la désescalade donc une logique
de dialogue avec avec les manifestants
donc moi je moi je me méfie toujours de
cet argument non pas en disant que la
violence se serait complètement
inexistante mais angers dire en la
restituant à sa réalité je crois que
aujourd'hui les mouvements désobéissants
globalement civils et sont globalement
pacifique que la violence n'est pas n'a
pas emporté véritable débat et j'ai
encore rarement vu des personnes via
même dans ma défense j'ai dans la
défense individuelle revendiquer des
actes de violence comme étant des actes
de pouvant s'inscrire dans une démarche
citoyenne dans une démarche militante
par exemple mlj jaune certains jeunes
qui ont pu être violents avec avec des
policiers disent non moi je je reconnais
que je peux avoir une part de
responsabilité
en revanche je l'expliquent par un
contexte mais l'acte en lui-même l'acte
de transgression est généralement
reconnu donc vraiment je pense qu'il
faut il faut se méfier non seulement de
resituer vérité dans ce que ce qu'est la
violence et il faut aussi prendre en
considération le fait que bien souvent
là des images de violence sont utilisés
par les pouvoirs publics pour
discréditer des mouvements et ça ça doit
aussi être pris en considération parce
que c'est notamment été une réalité pour
ligier jeunes qu'on a au départ
d'ailleurs voulu aussi marginalisée à
travers des expressions antisémite qu'on
a voulu marginalisés à travers des
vagues de violences avant de se rendre
compte aujourd'hui avec le recul que
c'était plus globale qu'il y avait des
revendications qui ne qui nous
intéressait tous et qui doivent aussi
être pris en considération dans le jeu
présidentiel
ce qui n'est manifestement pas le cas
aujourd'hui on se concentre uniquement
sur des questions de sécurité des
questions migratoires et on a
complètement oublié la crise la crise
institutionnelle donc vraiment cette
question de la violence je pense que
même s'il s'agit pas d'être dans le dans
le déni il faut il faut là la resituer
et voir sa réalité je vous remercie tous
les deux de voir patrie ps débat
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]